enquêter sur la déontologie des forces
de l'ordre voilà le rôle principal de
l'igpn cette institution que l'on
appelle aussi la police des polices et
où je me trouve actuellement n'a pas le
pouvoir de sanctionner directement
elle mène des enquêtes et peut proposer
des sanctions ou condamnation des
enquêtes en nette augmentation depuis
ces trois dernières années notamment sur
des violences volontaires
mais la plupart n'ont pratiquement
jamais abouti à des condamnations
judiciaires
pour bien comprendre il faut d'abord se
concentrer sur deux termes
les enquêtes ouvertes sont à la fois
administrative et judiciaire
le volet administratif se concentre
uniquement sur le fonctionnement interne
de la police
la procédure peut aboutir à des
sanctions disciplinaires pour ce qui est
du volet judiciaire les procédures
peuvent conduire à des peines prévues
par le code pénal
si je suis là pour condamner fermement
tous les policiers qui ne respectent pas
la déontologie
je voudrais dire tout mon soutien
profond à l'immense majorité des
fantômes qui risquent leur vie pour nous
condamner fermement tous les mauvais
policiers tout en réitérant son soutien
aux forces de l'ordre le ministre de
l'intérieur a voulu jeter un pavé en
eaux troubles
en parlant de pas mais ça me rappelle
quelque chose
des images qui ont choqué et surtout cet
homme est devenu le premier policier
être condamné pour des violences
volontaires depuis le début du mouvement
des gilet jaune
deux mois de prison avec sursis mais
elle pourra toujours exercé sa fonction
on l'espère avec 100 au monde dans les
mains et cette procédure fait partie des
1460 enquêtes judiciaires ouvertes en
2010 9 868 d'entre elles portaient sur
des violences volontaires par des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique
83 seulement abouti à des condamnations
judiciaires de ce type
un chiffre qui parle de lui-même et les
statistiques en général confirme la
rareté des poursuites judiciaires dans
les affaires de violences policières
exemple plus précis de ses statistiques
avec ce rapport de l' ong chrétienne à 4
publié en 2016 sur 89 situation a légué
de violences policières survenues en
france entre 2005 et 2015
celles dans lesquelles la justice
s'était prononcé au moment de la
rédaction de ce rapport s'était
majoritairement soldées par des
non-lieux
on relève un manque criard de
transparence sur les chiffres de ce
rapport le taux de poursuite des
policiers plus faible que pour le reste
de la population
alors comment expliquer tout simplement
car la preuve est difficile à apporter
la plupart devant quatre sont classées
sans suite car l'infraction principale
est insuffisamment caractérisée ça ne
veut pas dire que les faits ne se sont
pas produits
mais qu'il n'existe pas de preuves
suffisantes pour obtenir une
condamnation si des certificats médicaux
et des enregistrements vidéos sont
fournis dans certaines procédures les
témoins ne se manifeste en général pas
beaucoup
pour l'opposition c'est avant tout un
problème structurel d'une
interdépendance entre police et
politique ainsi qu'une démarche assumée
voire encouragée par la hiérarchie le
gouvernement le plus le mouvement des
ligier jeunes c'est qu'il tient par la
police et quelque part la police le tien
michel dont la tête quand même quand on
la voit
c'est stupéfiant le gars sait même pas
ko qui s'est pris sur internet sur un
ring quoi ce ne sont pas des faits
anecdotiques qui peuvent plus se traiter
pas on suspend les trois policiers s'ils
se sont sentis autorisés à faire ça
c'est parce que ils ont une autorisation
faire depuis maintenant deux ans un
problème qui fait de plus en plus de
bruit dans les couloirs de l'assemblée
nationale
prendre ses responsabilités et se
montrait intraitable envers les forces
de l'ordre prises en défaut et voilà
l'objectif affiché de gérald darmanin
mais les chiffres eux ne sont pas de cet
avis